son una pequeña decena hoy frente al
bundestag un lugar que consideran como
el corazón de un poder ilegítimo para
ellos la República Federal alemana es
una quimera y los alemanes unos
apátridas
la República Federal alemana pertenece a
Estados Unidos y al Reino Unido Este
parlamento es el brazo enfermo de ellos
[Música]
su líder hoffmann es conocido de los
servicios de seguridad
no reconoce el armisticio de 1945 y para
este grupúsculo Alemania sigue siendo un
territorio ocupado por los aliados
Alemania es una administración de los
aliados que manejan el país la Segunda
Guerra Mundial no ha terminado
esta República Federal ocupa simplemente
la patria de los alemanes o más bien
tribus alemanas a las que les pertenece
este territorio
un discurso complotista a veces
delirante pero menos inofensivo de lo
que parece Porque los miembros de este
grupo son Reich Burger ciudadanos del
Reich una nebulosa con perfil confuso
pero con un punto en común sus elementos
no reconocen la actual República Federal
alemana
según las autoridades 23.000 personas
harían parte del movimiento de los
ciudadanos del Reich muy cerca de
bittenberg la ciudad de Martín Lutero y
de la Reforma uno de estos grupos creó
una nueva monarquía
todos entramos en una fase donde hay que
tomar una decisión
permanecer en el camino de la condena
o tomar el camino más angosto de la luz
es jornada puertas abiertas en el
autoproclamado reino de Alemania una
propiedad privada de 9 hectáreas en la
que reina Peter
ausente este día el Antiguo cocinero
reconvertido en soberano prestó
juramento hace una decena de años su
reino contaría actualmente con 600
personas
aquí
del estado civil Porque el reino expide
sus propios documentos de identidad y
sus licencias de conducción
El joven hombre se separó de la
República Federal hace un año cuando se
posee un documento de identidad o una
licencia de conducción de la rfa se está
bajo contrato de este estado Yo no
quiero más hacer parte de este sistema
y quiero pertenecer de lleno al reino de
Alemania ya que el autoproclamado reino
de Alemania también es un negocio que
funciona
la organización creó su propio banco su
caja de jubilación Y su seguridad social
pequeñas empresas se han Unido y varias
propiedades han sido compradas gracias a
las donaciones los servicios de
seguridad consideran a los miembros de
esta organización de carácter sectaria
como ciudadanos del raich así su
portavoz lo critique formalmente
pensamos que hay que crear un nuevo
sistema de manera pacifista
y que no hay que emplear el odio y la
violencia para lograrlo porque ellos
solo engendrar a más odio y violencia
pero la gente que viene a vernos
considera efectivamente que un cambio en
el sistema es imposible y que hay que
salirse para construir algo nuevo
serían varias decenas de personas las
que han creado su reino Paralelo
microestados que podrían hacer sonreír
pero que registran una afluencia
creciente en especial desde la crisis
sanitaria la fundación Antonio que lucha
contra el racismo y el antisemitismo
Investiga desde hace más de 10 años
sobre este movimiento que se radicaliza
y cuyos lazos con la extrema derecha
están probados
la gente que entró a este proceso de
radicalización vive en una realidad
alternativa y yo puede parecer ridículo
incluso divertido pero esta realidad
alternativa los hace muy sensibles
frente a toda clase de ideologías
antidemocráticas y en el peor de los
casos para estos actos de violencia
una amenaza que se toma En serio el 7 de
diciembre una vasta operación de policía
desmanteló un grupo terrorista acusado
de fomentar un atentado contra el
parlamento entre ellos militares
notables pero también una juez antigua
diputada del partido de extrema derecha
afd un centenar de armas fueron
incautadas en el parlamento este
presunto proyecto de golpe de estado
provocó la estupefacción pero para esta
diputada de izquierda miembro de la
oposición el peligro no ha sido
descartado
estas personas están convencidas de que
siniestras potencias extranjeras están
por tomarse el poder
y el peligro reside en esa dinámica
uno de ellos puede decir voy y los otros
me seguirán y Sólo basta con uno un
individuo que entra en una mezquita para
fusilar a todo el mundo o un individuo
que logra ingresar lamento
en Berlín El parlamento ahora quiere
reforzar sus reglas de acceso Durante
los allanamientos del mes de diciembre
una lista de apellidos en la que figura
una veintena de personalidades públicas
fue descubierta en manos de uno de los
sospechosos